Hello everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Dissenter. I'm your host Ricardo Lops, and today I'm
joined by Kasper Hesp. He is a PhD candidate
in Social computational neuroscience at the University of Amsterdam.
His research aims to model and understand how social
life develops in individuals and over generations and going
from an Understanding of the emotional basis of social
life to modeling culture and today we're going to
explore topics like feelings and moods, the emotional basis
of social life, cultural evolution, active inference, phenomenology, and
some other related topics. So Casper, welcome to the
show. It's a big pleasure to everyone. Thank you.
So before we get into really specific topics of
your work, I would like to start by asking
you about basically the approach you have in your
work, the sort of framework you bring into it.
So what is active inference exactly?
It's a very fundamental question. Um, SO basically, we
Look at the Life as uh being involved in
the process of active inference. Um, Whether active inferences
a process or a framework, uh, it's actually still
it's a matter for philosophers to debate, but the
general approach is focused on, um, this notion that,
uh, every organism is engaged in Uh, keeping themselves
alive, uh, on one level or another. And so
it can be, uh, essentially focusing on different levels
of description. So groups of organisms, uh, essentially can,
well, let's say, sacrifice individuals uh for the greater
goods from their perspective, and And in this way,
um, Active inference is like a scale-free description of
a life. You can think of it like that,
where the active parts, uh. TRIES to go beyond
mere that what they call predictive processing. So I
suppose this is somewhat familiar to your audience at
this point, but Um, predictive processing focuses a lot
on the anticipatory part of life. Um, SO essentially
the The way of perceiving the world, anticipating the
future sensory inputs. The active parts actually goes beyond
that in the sense that it's not just about
anticipating what's going to happen and But also about,
let's say, changing the world and directing the states
of the future. And in exit inference we formalize.
We formalize that part as well as a form
of anticipation, but then it's about anticipating the, let's
say the consequences of action, um. I'm not a
huge fan of the predictive processing label because it's
sort of calls to mind, let's say um a
computer analogy of how the mind works and how
cognition works, and Uh, I, that's why I, I
generally prefer active, the label active inference because it's,
um, let's say a little bit more agnostic about
the, um, The underpinnings there's Let's say work from
people who are more, let's say um uh about
extended cognition and active uh frameworks but also People
who are more what they call internalists. Right, so
it leaves room for, let's say it's a white
tent, it leaves room for different perspectives. Uh, WHETHER
it's more internally focused or externally focused. And I
think that's also the power of it. And for
some people also the weakness, um, in the sense
that they like to have it, uh, well, especially
the philosophers, they like to have a clear cut
answer to these kinds of questions. Um, WELL, for
me, it's more a question of Scientific, um, Investigation,
let's say, to which extent things are internalized or
externalized. Anyways, so this is my long-winded answer to
this, uh, well, still. Uh, I mean you could
write entire books on this question, so actually they
have already been written, I know. Uh, YEAH, thanks.
Yeah,
no, no, that, that's perfectly fine, and I guess
that we'll also come back to it a little
bit later as we go through the other topics
and perhaps some of them it applies directly to,
but, uh, as I said in the introduction, you
are very interested in having a better understanding of
the emotional basis of social life and how we
go from there to culture, cultural evolution, and so
on. So perhaps starting at a more individual level
uh and uh with more basic psychological aspects of
our lives, what are feelings and moods and I
mean how do you understand them from the perspective
you come from?
Yeah, so when I came into this Let's say
this field, I realized that. There was still quite
a large gap between the formal descriptions, um, as
they have been, um, Uh, as they have been
developed in active inference and, um, let's say emotion
research and um emotion research has Uh, focused on
the social aspects of, um, of feelings and, uh,
moods. Um, I, that actually doesn't answer what they
are yet. I will get to that in a
second. Essentially, from an evolutionary perspective, um, It is,
well, it's like the consensus essentially that Um, all
our social interactions, uh, are sort of bootstrapped from
let's say core effect, um, core functionalities that's Um,
aligned with the evolutionary pressures over the, well, over
millions of years, right? So there's um The basic
feelings, uh, which I would start with defining there,
um. ARE essentially the The states of our system
focusing on Let's say being Driven by this more
uh. Let's call them evolutionarily ancient, um, parts of
our system. Um, AND the social, social dimension sort
of exploits those, uh, elements, so there's different dimensions
to this, like core, core effects. It's, um, something
that I know you, uh, I believe you're, you
have a few questions in your, you're also focused
on this in more detail, so I won't too
much, but, um. Essentially, the dimensions of positive and
negative uh valence are pretty important because Um We
believe at least uh the framework I've been developing
um looks at those as valence as aligning with
uh this, let's say, subjective fitness of organisms. And
so Um There's other dimensions to this. So essentially
feelings would be uh those very abstract states that
characterize whether we want to approach or avoid something,
whether we, uh, let's say are in a high
energetic state or in a relaxed state, um. There's
like Essentially emotion researchers have defined multiple axes this
whether we are in control or not, and Our
feelings in that sense. You could think of them
as What ties together the, the cognition in the
abstract sense and the biological substrate, let's say, um,
the biological constraints. OK, so there's feelings and then
moods, uh, I view them as more the, the
long term, um. Or let's say more slow characterizations
of that, so. Uh I mean, it depends on
what kind of researcher you talk to because some
uh uh psychiatrists might focus on moods patterns over
timescales of months, right? Um, But essentially, there's not
a very clear cut temporal distinction. It's just that
sort of like a The sea has waves, but
every wave has a smaller, uh, ripples, and. And
the moods, yeah, moods are basically this long term
patterns that we identify as feelings in our daily
lives. It's not, um, I guess I don't wanna
spoil too much for the follow-up questions.
Sure, uh, but I mean, here when it comes
to feelings and moods in your work, are you
interested in how they influence our behavior? I mean,
only that or also perhaps some potential top-down effects
that they might also have on our physiology. And
yeah, so that was what I was, well, trying
to get at with this uh link to the
biological substrate, essentially. So the, uh, let's say biasing
the responses of our, uh, neural systems, which includes
the, uh, things like, uh, hormonal releases, uh, Essentially,
The typical um. Let's say neuroscientific findings on um
the HPA axis. I don't know how familiar that
uh will sound to your audience, but Essentially the
The way that links to the, uh, well, the
core effects of every cell in your body. That,
that's, we think, yeah, includes um Neurotransmitters that are
being used to coordinate across all these different levels.
Mhm AND at a certain point there you also
mentioned emotional violence. So what is the importance of
emotional violence here and how does it work exactly?
Yeah, so emotional valence, um, You could see it
as a fundamental characteristic of uh our experience where
Uh, it represents whether we want more of something
or we want less of something. Um, AND it's
interesting cause behaviorally, people have linked it to approach
and avoidance, right? But Uh, that distinction has received
some criticism because, uh, well, one example of a
negative, um, emotion is anger. All right, which can
lead to aggression, which is a Uh, approach response
on the behavioral level, um, but on the abstract
level, you could think of anger, uh, as let's
say the intention to stop something from happening, right?
So the So in a sense, the approach response
on the short term. Actually, in this case, in
the case of aggression, kind of shows the Yeah.
Let's say the desire for something to be gone,
right? And The aggression in this case can be
In response to a conspecific, um. Or some other
threats. So that would be the sort of, uh,
let's say fear driven, uh, aggression, um. Which is
an interesting example where a behavioral distinction is too
simplistic. Right, so it's not just approaching avoidance, but
Uh, from an active Ace perspective, like trying to
remove something from your environment is also a form
of avoidance on that level. Yeah. Um Essentially emotional
valence is the uh core functionality that you could
even think of it uh on the level of
individual cells. So every cell, uh, even in your
guts, uh, right? So there's a whole microbio uh
biomes, and Whole ecosystems are regulating your, uh, digestive
system and each of the cells in that, uh,
those ecosystems has the possibility to, let's say um
emit uh signals of distress. Um, AND in that
sense, even a single-celled organism has a form of
emotional fence. Well, we would call that affective valence
because, um, there's this sort of like nuanced, uh,
distinction between affect and emotion. Um, WHERE we think
of emotion more as, let's say the socially contextualized,
um, Uh Phenomena that corporate affects, um, so think
of both are the emotions like sadness, fear, um,
anger. Um, Happiness Essentially all of them have a
sense of valence embedded. Um And That is, is,
well, from this theoretical perspective, those are, uh, essentially
the social, socially contextualized, um, narratives almost around the
more core affective states. That makes sense. Mhm
AND something that you also mentioned a few minutes
ago, uh, was core effect. So could you tell
us now what is core affect exactly and what
are its evolved functions?
Yeah, so I was mentioning, uh, this dimensions that,
uh, emotion researchers have been, um, working out. So,
uh, they, they view valence as like the first
axis, so to speak, the positive and negative valence,
uh, then you have, um, the, uh, let's say
activation level of, uh, let's say low energy and
high energy states, um. So you can be, you
can feel relaxed in a positive sense or tired,
uh, in a negative sense, and that's what we
call the affect circumplex. Um, IN the sense that
if you take these two principal axes, then you
can define a sort of a circle uh on
which you can Uh, actually Pinpoint a lot of
the different, uh, what we call affective states. And
those, uh, what are those states? Well, they're essentially
abstract descriptions of the way our body and our
minds work at any given point in time. In
that sense, it's, uh, pretty hard to pinpoint what
exactly it is, um. Because it's like a, it's
a. SUMMARY of the cross scale phenomenon in this
case our body and minds. Uh, OH, we are
not dualists these days, at least I don't know
any, uh, so they're essentially one, and we're just,
um, let's say, Uh, looking at it from different
perspectives, right? And what's interesting about A effect is
that where, that's where they seem to Come together,
so to speak. Um, SO I said the two
dimensions, but core effect has more than 2, right?
You can, you can extend it, uh, the third
dimension that's typically included is a sense of control.
So whether you have control over a situation or
not. Um Let's say a child, a young child,
can feel happy and energetic. Um, WELL, even though
they, I don't know, their parents is pushing the,
uh, Uh, the swing, so they don't have any
control over what's happening, but they feel safe and
they feel happy, right, um, so in that sense
there's like dimensions where you don't have control. It's
different from the sense of, um. Yeah, where you
do exert control over the environment and more directly
and Anyways, so there's this I believe there's a
few more dimensions on top of this, but it
gets more and more, let's say elusive after this
1st 3.
So in a related topic, I guess, what role
does communication with con specifics play in effect from
an evolutionary perspective, of course.
Mhm. Yeah, so, um, I was mentioning before that
even, um, microorganisms in your gut are, uh, communicating
each their affective states in a sense. Um, SO
literally just like if they don't get enough, um,
Uh, glucose or something like that, they will indicate
their discontent, uh, the discontentment in Very fundamental sense,
and that's how in the end, uh, you end
up, uh, feeling hungry, right? So there's a sense
in which um that helps your system on the
level of um the human body to coordinate, um,
And in that sense, the The reason why effect
is important or useful way to characterize systems is
Living systems is actually Um, already evidenced in, in
the way they use it, in the way we
have, um, let's say, Uh, the multicellular organisms have
been using this kind of communication to uh, to
organize themselves. Um. Where, well, literally, if you have
pain, right, that this part of your body is.
Uh, DETECTING a departure from, uh, their expectations, so
to speak, but uh. Regular biological function. And then
that will trigger attention uh to deal with that
source, the source of the pain. So, um, anyway,
that's some level of one individual, right? But the
idea is that, um, In the same way that
cells can organize to form larger tissues and tissues
can organize to form organs and organs can form
can organize to form. Entire organisms, um, like and
mammals in the end, um, the same way people
can organize to form larger bodies together, um. And
the communication of affects just like it's important for
that organization within the body of a single person,
it becomes the Let's say the sort of glue
uh that uh allows larger, uh, groups of people
to form coordinated units. So, I mean, you can
see this very clearly in the In the development
of children, right? So the, uh, communication. Of uh
the affective state of the baby, sort of. Drives
the parents' uh behaviors or in a, well, in
what we think of as a healthy parental relationship,
and the affective state of the baby will basically
be determining most of their activities. Um. Anyways, so
that's like where, uh, because the baby is essentially,
well, starts as an organism, a part of the,
literally part of the body of its mother, um,
then transitions to becoming an independent, to some degree
independent, uh, organism, but Um, from the perspective of
let's say, swarm intelligence, so to speak, uh, they
still keep, they, they keep being connected in many
cases, um, and they form a body. Uh, IF
you But on the abstract level, you could think
of groups of people as forming bodies on a
larger, uh, larger spatial temporal scale, essentially. Mhm.
So is this why we need to track each
other's feelings to be able to coordinate socially?
Uh, YES, and there's a. There's an interesting complication
there in terms of like cooperation versus competition. And
It is, it all happens also in within our
bodies. So there is a competition for attention, let's
say, between Well, let's say when I'm uh Have,
I'm in a positive flow um during my work,
but I'm getting a little bit hungry. Then there
starts to be competition for, uh, let's say the
prioritizing the different needs of my system. And this
similar thing happens within uh human systems, right? So
there's, uh, of course, um, The extent to which
people communicate their needs varies a lot, uh, oh,
the communication itself, but then also the extent to
which others, uh, let's say, respond to those needs,
um. CORRELATES with um What we call esteem, social
esteem. So the idea is that From a very
early stage, this It's a social network with Let's
say different prioritization of, of different, uh, hubs of
the network, sort of, uh, determine The social Dynamics
that we experience every day and I mean some
of my simulations and on that front are sort
of reminiscent of a high school class where like
uh you have uh different agents forming opinions about
each other's opinions. So like they have a sort
of a, well let's say they're inferring each other's
opinions about each other and they are looking for
a certain level of validation because there's no other.
Characteristic in this setting and. And then that way
they Well, I guess I was just linking that
because you're mentioning about uh like cooperation, right, but
then in the, in practice you see that both
competition and cooperation are pretty important.
ACTUALLY, uh, the, the word I used was coordination,
so I'm not sure if that always implies cooperation.
No, you're right, yes, I think coordination is a
nice way to Um, Yeah, because there's essentially a,
uh, the, the competition aspect basically also leads to
a form of coordination, yeah. Which is not always.
Beneficial to the, to the entire system, but um
It nevertheless, yes, I think coordination is a nice
way, like a neutral way to formulate it, um,
but that, uh, let's say I am, my research
is focused on Let's say the 4 our forms
of different forms of coordination emerge from let's say
cooperative modes and competitive modes, right. And then that
relates back to core effects in a sense uh
you see that um when people categorize others as,
let's say, um, in-group versus outgroup you see that
first triggers more cooperative, um, modes versus more competitive
modes, um. Anyways, so that's how this core effect
in the end links back to one of the
many ways in which it links back to social
phenomena. Um
So since we're already getting it at the social
slash collective level, I would like to ask you
now, why do you think that we need to
start from an understanding of the emotional basis of
social life in humans in this case I guess
mostly to then study culture and cultural evolution.
Um, YES, OK. So essentially, I think, uh. If
you list, uh, if the, let's say the viewers
have listened, uh, very carefully to what I said
before, you could sort of infer probably in my
answer already, but, um, I think it's interesting always
to make it more explicit so that your questions
really help. So essentially if you go back to
this. Um, FORMULATION I described, um, of Active inferences
this kind of cross-scale description and then a level
of organization requires a form of communication between uh
elements of the, of the system. And in order
for a, uh, let's say a larger scale of
organization to merge, there must be a certain degree
of alignment. Within the elements of the system. So
then the uh communication of affects essentially um Ends
up being the crucial, or what I called glue
before. Um. So the notion would be that Uh,
Our cells have learned to communicate with each other
in coherent ways. I mean, it goes wrong sometimes.
That's what we call uh cancer, right? So, uh,
tumors are forms of, uh, also forms of life,
but it just happens to be that they're. Um,
VALENCE, let's say, factor or tensor, uh, doesn't align
with the, uh, uh, the goals, uh, of the
larger system, right? So there's this in which they're
sort of like, uh, greedy, um. Uh, BEHAVIOR of
the, the tumor, which is also, I mean, fascinating
how, how it can organize itself at such large
scale. But it misaligns with the intentions of the
system as a whole, so you have, let's say
immune system developed to counteract this, and so. Uh,
IF we lift this to the societal level, um,
you can think of. And this degree of alignment
being crucial for a society, no matter how small,
to Be sort of uh working towards common goals
in the long. And And also competing, uh, internally,
right? So there's a sense in which, uh, humans
have always been competing with each other, um. And
also externally, of course. So there was, there were
times when it was much harder to, to get
your food on your plate, so to speak. So.
Um. Our cultures have have been. Let's say, built
around this kind of competitive modes, and Where you
have more, uh, let's say cooperation more internally and
uh competition more externally. Um, WE'VE been trying to
get, uh, uh, well, at least I believe we,
we've been trying to Build beyond that, right? To
think of human life as like one big family,
um, but this kind of, uh, Let's say local
selfishness of groups of individuals, a few others as
That's the enemies. It's, it's very, yeah, let's say
it's deeply encoded into our cultural uh heritage and
Mm, not for bad reasons. I mean, uh, I,
I was mentioning this notion of a tumor, right?
So if there's a small, it's a relatively small,
um, A subgroup that doesn't align with the goals
of the society as a whole that You need
an immune system, so to speak, to get rid
of this. Uh Let's say parasitical, uh, behavior or
like, uh, yeah, entities. I mean, that's what our
police uh supposed to be doing in a way,
right, in society. So, um, The police is an
interesting example of an institutionalized um version of this,
but in a way, we're all uh sort of
policing each other well, subconsciously. Um, WE look We
gauge to which extent other people's opinions are sort
of Um, let's say, Aligned with society as we
view it as individuals and You see a lot
of that in I know if you've been doom
scrolling the recent events on the news, but there's
all the time a sort of Yeah Yeah, let's
say Um, negative and positive. Uh, EVALUATION of, uh,
yeah, of other people's World models you could say
so. That's I mean, a very interesting and very,
I think, relevant, um, topic, especially when you get
political polarization and, and Of course, like cross-generational. CONFLICTS
that are essentially If let's say you have an
alien intelligence studying our species, it sort of looks
like swarm, uh, like different swarms, sort of, uh,
um. Competing for dominance in a in a sense
and War in that sense is a Unfortunate, let's
say heritage from our Our biological origins, I guess,
or yeah. I think, um. I hope we can
get rid of it, but I mean, uh, yeah,
it seems like. We have a long way ahead
of us, right? Um, BUT, yeah, I guess to
come back to your point on, uh, what is
the relevance of affect to cultural evolution, well, Essentially,
it's a way of linking the cultural and the
biological side of our um our uh You could
say learning processes. So there's something what we call
gene culture co-evolution, and yes, and This works through
all levels. I mean, I mentioned war, which is
sort of like an extreme example, but it's also,
let's say you had a perfect world that was
just peaceful. I don't know if we're going to
make it there, but let's say that we had
one, even then it would drive evolution because you
would have, let's say, partner selection based on things
that appeal to you, right? And there needs certain
alignment between Oh, in stable relationships, you have a
form of alignment. Or at the very least a
formal stable, uh. Uh, LET'S say if there's misalignment,
then the two models sort of need to fit
together like a jigsaw puzzle, so to speak, um.
I'm just saying that even if you cancel all
this like extreme examples, uh, our culture, the way
it evolves would still be connected to the biological
level as well. Uh, AND the effect is essentially
this connect, connecting piece, I would say. Yeah, and
then the emotional side is sort of like the
Let's say the perspective from the cultural level, um,
and the effects description is more the biological, uh,
perspective on the same phenomenon. Mhm
And and so from this approach, how do you
understand cumulative culture? What is cumulative culture exactly?
Yeah. And so there it's essentially a Uh phenomenon
of Let's say, uh, bootstrapping, uh, that, I don't
know how many people are familiar with the term
bootstrapping, but comes from this notion of pulling yourself
up by your own bootstraps, right? So we, um,
We've built our societies on. Um On the basis
of very fundamental biological, uh, needs, right, so we,
uh, sort of reminiscent of, um, uh, Maslow's pyramid
of needs, right. It's interesting because he thought of
it as a hierarchy, but within active inference it
becomes more like what we call a heterarchy, so
where there's no strict. There's no strict hierarchy within
this needs, sets of needs, but There's a sense
in which each of them builds on the Previous
one. I mean, I'm leaving the top, uh, I,
I can list them in a second, but the,
the top one is a little bit controversial, uh,
we Uh, but the bottom, it starts with biological
needs, right? So you can't, uh, well, if you,
if you can't keep your own body alive, then
there's not much culture to, to, um, to do.
Then if you, then you have the safety needs,
right? So that's sort of like safeguarding the biological
needs. Um, FROM there, you have the social, what
they call social needs or belonging needs, um. So
the idea is that once you are able to
safeguard biological needs, then you can start sort of
building. Safe space, social safe space. This a safe
space that's In a recursive sense helps you to
safeguard your biological needs, right? So there's this sort
of I think the notion of a pyramid is
a little bit misleading in this sense, but, um,
functionally it makes sense, um, from this point of
belonging. Like once you belong somewhere, uh, on top
of that you get the esteem needs, right? So
the sense of respect. That um within a social
group, um. Sense of, uh, essentially, if you don't
belong anywhere, you, you can't learn to monitor, um,
to which extent you're being, uh, respected within the
group. Anyway, so then, um, Maslow built on top
of that the notion of self-actualization, which is sort
of like his I mean, he had a very,
uh, let's say. Ivory tower kind of perspective on
this self-actualization, um, which is like in his mind,
only the greatest minds achieved this like, uh, Einstein,
or something like that, but I like to think
it more as like a generalized thing of like
um developing your career, you know, or developing your
um Uh, let's say your dreams as a, as
a person, um, so it's Something that, uh, on
the, on the human level, um, You could say
the capstone, uh, can be something like self-eviddencing, um.
And then if you make the capstone in that
sense more general, then you can extend it to
the way you describe animals as well, and where
the self-evidencing is a more, has less socio-cultural dimensions
or less social cultural, um, complexity, let's say, um.
To come back to your point of cumulative culture,
so that's important in terms of the distinction with
the other animals, right? So And the capacity. To
learn each other to, uh, sorry, to, to teach
each other to um teach the next generation, right?
So there's this sort of um recursive characteristic that's
Um I was mentioning before that we managed to
sort of bootstrap ourselves uh to this level, and
what's interesting is that, um, it relates to this
notion, I saw in your, your history, you, um,
interviewed quite a few people that work with complex
systems theory, um. And there's this notion in complex
systems theory of enslavement. So where a lower level,
um, let's say, Uh A more fundamental level of
organization is being enslaved by an um let's say
a level of organization that was built on top
of it and um It's very interesting because this
seems to have happened with emotions where We nowadays
we write stories. About, uh, different, let's say, uh,
emotional patterns and those driving our, uh, real-time biological
states, right? So, um, Cumulative culture in that sense
is a Um Process of building on top of
this more ancient uh functionality, but then in the
end, driving it into uh directions that are quite
atypical. I mean, a few examples are like Of
very extreme cases are, uh, like fasting practices, right?
So intentionally holding foods from your system to to
attain certain kinds of states, which is sort of
There's no, there are no animals that do this
on a culture like in a sort of like
group level, and it doesn't seem to make sense.
From, uh, well, from a biological standpoint, and I
reckon, um. But cultural practices have emerged to like
um support that those kinds of things and um
anyway, so in that sense cumulative culture because it
builds the generations uh built on top of each
other and uh able to transmit. Um Essentially the
know-how, uh, or like the intimate knowing of the
practices to next generations. Um. That's where things get
really interesting, and we can basically reach, um, let's
say, We can reach domains that are expressions of
life that are different from just biological evolution, right?
So that's why the gene culture co-evolution becomes really
important. Um, ANYWAY, so as I said before, there's
like entire books on most of the questions that
that you've asked, there's entire books to rewritten. Mhm,
uh, SO perhaps let's get here into an example
of, uh, some or, or a type of cultural
practice that you approach through active influence here just
for people to get perhaps an illustrative example of
what we're talking about so. Uh, IN the case
of religion, uh, tell us about how we can
understand religious practices and at a certain point there
you mentioned fasting, for example. I'm not saying that
that's always a form of religious practice, but we
see that in certain religious contexts, but how, how
we can understand religious practices in general as multi-scale
active inference.
Yes, and So it's, it's a very crucial piece
also, um, because I was mentioning, uh, distinction with
other animals, right, and, uh, researchers have written a
lot on, well, the expression of religion seems to
be, um, one of the let's say the easiest
uh distinctions to, to make. Um, THERE'S nothing, it
doesn't seem to be any kind of spiritual awareness
and, uh, in terms of like a shared practices
that uh other animals have. Um And religion, I
like to go back to the, let's say the
tribe, uh, religions, the, the ancient ones, uh, to
understand this and see how it relates to the
modern religions as well. Um. Because the tribe, uh,
let's say, understanding of religion is more focused on
Say worshiping, uh, the continuity of the ancestors, right?
So the um sense in which every tribe had
their own ancestral, uh, spirits that's the represent their,
uh, community and I was talking earlier about uh
people are that organized into bodies, right? uh AT
a larger scale and from the perspective from this
like cross, let's say from the scale agnostic perspective
of active inference, you could think of the tribe
gods literally representing uh the agents of the tribe
as a whole, uh, that they are um Basically
honoring the continuity of their, their tribe. Um, AND
in that sense, The narratives that they have and
share keep this. OK. Group, um, organized into a
stable, uh, well, organism at this as a larger
scale. Interesting there is that used to be tied
very strongly to biological. Uh, TIES, right? So, there
was this sort of alignment between notion of religion
and the biological organ level of organization. And then
the modern religions have sort of, well, let's say,
Not all modern religions, but, um, uh, certain, um,
religions have innovated on top of this by saying
that you can say convert, uh, to a religion.
And based on your individual. Perspective, which is a
very different. A type of organization, right, so you
get A sort of accumulation of Followers that is
not just biological um where Um, I mean, I,
I haven't talked about the content much, but, uh,
in the, the paper that you're referring to, or
actually it's a book chapter I wrote, um, with
Dinesh Hipolito. Who I think you have interviewed as
well in the previous,
I've on the show twice.
OK, nice, um. Anyway, so, um, We were talking
that, that uh chapter we are describing how um
the shared symbols, uh, actually that uh people have
actually get meaning from the fact that others are
using it in the same way. So there's a
sort of circular sense in which Um, religious activities,
uh, acquires meaning through the practice of, uh, other
agents in that sense. Um, IT'S not really, it's
sort of from a scientific perspective, it's not really
a question of like, is it true what they're
like the narratives, whether those narratives are true, but
the, because the uh meaning in practice is from
the shared, uh, Um, Let's say the shared um.
Let's say generative models we could consider them like
this, um, in which they live their social lives
right so It sort of gives you a nice
way to study those phenomena without being um. Without
sort of rejecting any specific religious beliefs, right? So
it gives you a way to study them without
um Making them, uh, yeah, I know, I think
that in the past, certain scientists have made the
mistake of being sort of condescendent towards, uh, religion.
Um, Well, there seems to be an obvious sense
in which At the very least, it has played
a crucial role in the emergence of societies, and
it seems to still play a crucial role in
Um, let's say spiritual, uh, experience as people report
around the world, um. And this, I think, deserves
proper attention, you know, there is a certain thirst.
Netherlands, we have a very secular, uh, approach to,
um, Yeah, basically to governance and, and all of
that, but at the same time, I mean, we
have, uh, we have political parties named after religions
in our uh system. Um, SO there is a
thirst, uh, people who are looking for some kind
of shared narrative that gives guidance, um, and a
lot on this moral level, right? So, um, I
believe that has a very crucial link to what
we talked about in terms of this alignment, sort
of core effect, essentially, so. Figuring out what is
the sort of shared cultural DNA of um uh
on the moral level, uh. And sharing this with
our offspring and our, well, specifics basically, um. That
has turned out pretty hard to do without some
kind of religious framing. We do try to do
this. There's like the secular, yeah. Um Let's say
organization of society also tries to. Um, SHARE certain
moral, uh, guidelines, but in practice, Uh, yeah, this
has turned out quite hard to do, right? The
multicultural society right now is sort of Um, yeah,
uh, under a lot of pressure, let's say. All
across the world, um. It's interesting to think of
the conflicts that are happening now also on this
level. I mean, And yeah, the Jewish, uh, and
Islamic religions both have a certain sense of uh
heritage, inheritance that is important. Um, AND, um, the
populations that are linked to this have, um, been
Let's say in tension with each other for many,
many, uh, well, thousands of years now, I guess,
um. And you see that actually throughout human history,
right? So different religions, um, Well, exert pressure on
each other. Uh, SO that's why I was talking
about it like from a some alien species were
studying us. It's like sort of, uh, a science
they would think of religions. As descriptions of this
kind of swarm intelligence, uh, uh, where there are
different swarms that are sort of, um, let's say
each swarm has different kind of, um, uh Let's
say different kind of practices and they can, those
practices can um conflict with each other. Um, ESPECIALLY
if there's a sense of, um, Let's say Adversarial,
uh. Uh, A sense of adversarial, um. This, yeah,
disposition toward each other. So there's um Uh Throughout
human history, a lot of efforts in different societies,
a lot of effort has been made to ban
certain religions or something like that, right? There's even
within, yeah, uh, Anyway, I guess what I'm saying
is that they're sort of uh Part of the
immune system in a way. Um, AND we, uh,
we have transitioned to the secular world, sort of
like a social, political Structuring, but um. What you
see still is that The religions are I don't
think they will disappear. So, uh, that's sort of
hope to create a purely secular society, I think
it's quite, yeah. Mistaken, but We have seen an
evolution and Um To bring it back to the
notion of gene culture coevolution. Uh, AND the notion
of bootstrapping, at least from my perspective. Uh, THE
simpler narratives that we inherited. I believe will have
to be replaced over time, but not as a
whole, like. Canceled, but More, um, let's say stripped
from certain details that were specific of the past,
um, and like made more to our liking as
a society as a whole, but that's Uh, hard
to do. It's sort of like determining uh on
the individual level, like determining what, what do you
want your life to look like, um. And then
as a society, you would have to sort of
converge to something like what do we want our
future world to look like? Um, AND I Um
I think that instead of Removing the all the
religions, we, we just have to make sure that
there's like a sort of alignment, uh. I mean,
yeah, something very basic that could they could start
with, uh, I mean, I know this is not
a social political podcast, but, uh, my suggestion would
be that we at least look at whether it's
aligns with our, uh, constitution. Unfortunately, there's like quite
a few components of this ancient, uh, uh, yeah,
religions or ancient scriptures, let's say, that are not
in line with our constitution at the moment. Uh,
I think that could be, uh, some place to
start, like make, make sure that, uh, There's an
alignment on that fundamental core effect level, right? Um,
Anyways, so there's interesting answers that people can formulate
if you have this sort of cross-scale perspective, and
religion isn't. Nice example where you Instead of just
blank having a blanket rejection, you can actually start
to formulate sort of ways forward. They're more hopeful.
Have you seen my eyes? Mhm.
Great so um getting now into the last part
of our conversation today, I would like to ask
you a little bit about phenomenology because that's also
something that you bring into your work and I
mean first of all uh how can we naturalize
something like phenomenology.
Yeah, this is a very uh difficult question that
uh I, I've contributed to some uh publications to
that, to try and start formulate an answer to
that question um. It relates quite closely to what
drove me originally to go in this direction. I
have a background in astrophysics, but also in cognitive
neuroscience, so that's And. In astrophysics, it's, I was
sort of missing the human dimension, so to speak,
um, and Uh, in cognitive neuroscience, I was hoping
to find To study essentially how it is possible
that um all these complex processes that are happening.
Give rise to a sense of, um, let's say,
uh, a sense of unified. Conscious experience. Like this
sort of focal points you could say. Uh, AND
that's where the phenomenology actually, uh, I, I didn't
know at the time there's a whole tradition focused
on that, but um, I've, yeah, of course. Work
enough with uh different kinds of philosophers to know,
to, um, to learn about the different authors that
have been written on this topic and um I
won't pretend to be a philosopher in that sense,
but the way I am. The way I view
it is relevant is that Uh The stream of
consciousness in my research has been a very useful,
um, Heuristic, let's say, on formulating models that ended
up panning out quite well. Um, SO in that
sense, it's a very intuitive. WAY I came at
this where uh I've tried, I've been trying to
understand my own conscious experience and And working out
models to understand that actually has led to a
lot of my um Uh, research that's Ask, uh,
let's say. A lot of connections with previous findings,
right? So, um, I, as a teenager, I was
trying to figure out why in certain kinds of
social settings, um, your expectations can, if it, let's
say the world departs from your expectations, you feel,
uh, good, let's say, a positive surprise. Any other
kinds of settings, uh, where it departs from your
expectations, you feel bad, like a disappointment, right? So,
um. I mean, I'm just saying that I used
my own phenomenology of my own conscious, consciousness, uh,
to Develop some of the early ideas about uh
effect. I sort of, um, I try to understand
the structure of my experience and And why, uh,
Let's say departures from expectations leads to positive versus
negative tailings. And, and in this case, Well, at
the time, I didn't have a formal like a
mathematical way to describe it, but uh I was,
I was developing that um based on this. NOTION
of uh The simplest model that we try to,
uh, let's say we have certain neural pat patterns
and that characterize this, uh, simplest model of our
environment, um, or at least the simplest model that
captures the relevant parts and Um, I was thinking
of it like. Action possibilities that bring us to
uh Let's say. That can realize our needs, um,
and then departures from, uh, expectations that's, let's say
shrink that space of action possibilities would be uh
more associated with negative effects, right? So let's say
you Uh, you lose your house because it's got,
uh, turned, well, there was like a fire or
something in your neighbor's house. Uh, WELL, then you
basically lose the, um, literally lose the action possibilities
that you used to have in that space, and
You The expansion is similar. I mean, let's say
you win the lottery or something, there's like a
lot of different simple examples you can think of.
I guess what I'm saying here is that um,
We are in a very unique position where we
are, uh, if you're studying consciousness, then you have
a very, you have a first person perspective on
this, right? So you Can You have a lot
of data about conscious experience because you are yourself
a human being, and And that's what I find
quite interesting is that if you That you can
start formulating generative models that represent That conscious experience
to some degree. Um I mean, I I do
want to add a note there of nuance where
um. There's interesting perspectives on like, uh, let's say
parallel streams of consciousness, that's sort of like, let's
say come together and then diverge again. So there
might not just one, maybe we're all just experiencing,
um, let's say simultaneous streams that sort of converge
and then diverge again, um, but you're only Locally
you only have access to one of them. Right?
So this could be one perspective, but within active
inference, you could describe that as well. So that's
sort of agnostic to that, in that extent. It
doesn't say. Let's say I formulate a generative model
that characterizes this particular stream of consciousness that I'm
currently on, um, It doesn't prove that I have
captured the entire phenomenology yet, right, because there could
be other parallel streams and that I, I know
how much you've read about the split brain research,
but I think that's pretty fascinating line of work
where um They implement, well, because of other reasons,
right? They literally split the brains of people and
then gave them different tasks and They basically gave
a task to the task to the right, uh,
half of the brain and then asked the left
half like why they did a certain action. Um,
And people would come up with an explanation, and
they would believe that this was A truthful description
of why they did something, OK. I think from
a phenomenological perspective it's super interesting because the Supposedly
if the right half of the brain had control
over the Your verbal expression, it would say something
else. And so it would just say, yeah, because
the experiment that gave the instruction and. Of course,
it's sort of like an unnatural example where you
split the biological system, um. And we also know
that over time this integration sort of returns, so
it was only like the first few weeks or
something after the operation, but Anyways, uh, what I'm
saying I suppose is that the phenomenological side is
very important, um, Data on um how to model
the system as a whole. It seems like Actually,
it has an interesting link to the notion of
uh spirituality and then also religion, um, because people
note that they have this sort of like oneness
experience, let's say, um, of being, sense of being
part of something greater than themselves, um. And It
seems like in our phenomenological Um History, let's say,
well, at least the descriptions that people have given
of experience and this sort of thirst for being
part of something greater seems to drive. Um, ARE,
are, uh. Let's say our self-organization into larger Being
a larger whole together. Um, ANYWAY, so this is
like a long, long answer again but uh Yeah,
we can go in the phenomenology of uh an
interesting part of my research is focusing on this
notion of empathy. And you have affective empathy and
uh what you call affective empathy and cognitive empathy,
right, so um Affective empathy is more the sort
of like reflexive, uh, where you automatically experience the
affective state of another uh person and, and cognitive
empathy is more like where you Infer like a,
let's say some kind of reasoning process of how
a person might feel in a situation and And
this is a very important component, uh, again, where
the phenomenology becomes like part of the story because,
for example, to Empathize with a, uh, another animal,
right, that's not a human, and It sort of
implies that they have this. Well, some form of
experience, so, and. And so, yeah, anyway, so conscious
of, well, let's say our awareness of this, you
know, like what it means to be conscious and
the phenomenology of this, and ends up playing a
big role in all kinds of of lines of
research and decision making across society, so. Um, I
suppose there your answer, uh sorry, a question to
your Uh A follow-up question to your earlier one.
We basically focus on the applications, right? So the,
what is the use of studying phenomenology. Um, SO
that's, that's just like an Active empress being a
background in this case, more right and Um, Quite
an important one when you get to the details.
Let's say you want to know whether an application
you're developing is experienced as. Smooth, fluent, um, then
you would actually be. You won't want to have
an accurate model of the user experience in that
case, right? Um, SO not just of their biological
substrate, so to speak, uh, but of the system
as a whole and how it's sort of like
in the end comes together in their experience. Um,
ANYWAY, so. Modeling those aspects, there's an obvious. Universal
benefit to that and to minimize suffering, let's say,
and to maximize, uh, yeah, the fluency of, uh,
experience.
So, uh, just before we go then, uh, would
you like to tell people perhaps what would be
some of your future research topics? I mean what
are you interested in studying at the moment and
particularly after your PhD potentially?
Mhm Yeah, so Uh, I already mentioned, uh, actually,
yeah, just now I mentioned the Potential for developing
applications, let's say, um, and from an early stage
in my career I've already done some business activities.
I believe that uh to Make sure that the
academic research doesn't end up on the shelves. We
really need to have more hybrids, researchers that are
doing academic work, but also um developing applications and
um Let's say not just doing some consultancy on
the side, but actually sort of like helping. Businesses
or developing their own businesses through And Let's say
be a To make an integra, uh, let's say
in a positive impact in the world, it's The
danger is it gets sort of into just making
profit or something like that, or Uh, just trying
to monopolize certain tech technology, um, and I have
in my career I've benefited extremely from the open
source community, so like I mean obvious examples are
Python and everything that's been derived from it. I
actually was born in the Netherlands, Python and the
language and Many other aspects from the, let's say,
the Google ecosystem, you know, not everything is open
source, but still they have, I mean. Let's say
they have uh Completed capitalism to the extent that
they can give back a little bit, I think,
um. And We need more bridges in a sense.
So instead of people just getting sort of absorbed
into proprietary companies, we We need bridges that I
also have this sort of um Open source oriented,
uh, approach that many academics like to take. Now
it's very split, right, so, um. It's getting, I'd
like to believe it's get, has gotten better, um,
that's still a lot of work to do, um.
I like to develop applications of this kind, kind
of research that Include this kind of computational work
that I've been doing to make um Let's say
health applications. Um SO I've invested time and energy
in um developing models of this affective states that
connected biological uh data, biometric data, um, with people's
daily life, uh, their experience, and This has tremendous
uh implications for, let's say, health, uh, uh, monitoring
of um vulnerable groups. So that will be sort
of like on, well, let's call it the Um,
damage reduction sites. So that's an obvious uh application.
There's also the more general uh benefits. So just
helping people to live healthier lives or lives that's
Uh, let's say, achieve a better cross-scale, uh, fit,
so to speak. Um, SO I hope there's this
notion what we call tugging. So there's, um, often
dynamical systems, multi-scale systems, you can't really change them,
like just giving in an instruction, and then you're
better, you know. You just actually it works much
better if you get sort of targeted, um. Let's
say targeted. Uh, PUSHES, little pushes that help you
to uh find uh Let's say, a way to
change your structure of your daily life that fits
better, right? So, uh, this feedback to your own
experience, human experience is very important there. Um Because
what I just described could very quickly become sort
of like a big brother is watching you kind
of a situation, um, but yeah, anyway, so the,
the models I, I described, they're quite lightweight. They
can be locally deployed often, so you could make
them completely private, right? So there's people can protect
their privacy. Well, um, I mean, within this. Let's
say the constraints that they That suit their use
case, right? So there's, if there's larger risks, then
people can choose to be more transparent towards their
doctor, psychiatrist, something like that, and Anyway, so that's
in health applications. Or, yeah, there's different ways to
go at this, right? So you can go more
from the general population, um. And like fitness and
health, but you can also go into the medical
area. Essentially improving the user experience but also I
mean, we know that in a lot of institutions,
uh, the There's a lot of pressure on the,
well, let's say doctors in hospitals you have doctors,
surgeons, They actually sort of get Um, so much
pressure that then they sort of have to be
replaced, and we're not being very um Yeah, let's
say, um, we're just exerting pressure without having like
a way to, uh, correct along the way, um.
Of course they tried to, but oftentimes there's a
certain way in which I mean, burnout has been
accumulating so often only when it goes. Uh, THINGS
really go wrong, so to speak, we start to
attribute resources, um, from a, if you translate this
back to where we started, it's like a cell,
uh, when the cell is already almost about to
collapse and then it's, uh, you start to bring
some, in some resources to care for them. Um,
WHAT I'm talking about is essentially you could I
have more like a preventive healthcare, so mental health
would be more like a general, like a universal.
Uh Service that everybody is receiving instead of. Um,
TRYING to help people after things went, uh, totally,
totally escalated. That will be some things I would
be focusing on, um. Anyway, so you can apply
this to different levels of description, so this notion
of Creating more resilient systems uh by Having these
adaptive models that cross uh incorporate these cross-scale dynamics
that go down from individuals to Let's say companies
to entire societies. Um Incorporating the social networks, you
could essentially help governance. There's applications. Uh, I have,
I've not read, I haven't done it directly, but
um, There's obvious applications as well in monitoring um
crime, let's say, or yeah, detecting crime networks, um,
and sort of In a privacy sensitive way, so
you Um, make sure you don't end up being
like um. End up in the big, big brother
is watching you scenario, right? So you, you sort
of would have to locally balance the risks and
the privacy constraints of individuals. Um Anyways, so those
are, those are like the Interesting applications, but I've
stayed away from those, uh, because they're a little
bit too, mm, let's say. Uh I, I, there's
a Dutch term for this, but essentially, They're too
hot to touch from, you know, like those security,
uh, applications, um. And the issue is also that
I like to keep things open source and obviously
once you start getting into those topics, then the
government will ask you to keep your things.
Yeah, yeah,
I get. Yeah. Anyways, so I think there's uh
interesting applications there, but I, yeah, I can't, I
can't go into that third direction um without having
to lock myself. Well, not, it won't be a
paywall, but it will be like uh, yeah, some
kind of level of secrecy that I think would
be best for the research community. So yeah, I
haven't figured out that, that trade-off yet. That's why
for now, it will be mostly the fitness and
health uh direction that The most direct applications of
my work. I mean, I also do. Uh, THINGS
in um. Let's say, content generation, so integrating um
these large language models. Into um. Dynamical systems that
can help content generators to Let's say, increase engagement
with their, um, with their content, um, which can,
by the way, include podcasts like yours. Um, BUT
that's That's more like uh something I, let's say
I like to do in addition, it's more. Like
a side gig, so to speak. You think uh
Let's say, I was talking about health, right, which
is important but fun or let's say education, uh,
yeah, it's equally important, uh, in my experience, so
I guess if you, yeah, if you summarize it,
it would be like health, education, and entertainment. Those
would be the fields where I'd like to contribute.
Great, and by the way, where can people find
you on the Internet?
Um, WELL, there's my website, CSR.com. Um, I Uh,
I'm currently in this, um, final process, uh, wrapping
up my thesis work. Um, SO the website is
currently, I mean, contains references to my publications and
all of that. So my Google, Google Scholar profile
that barely shows my, uh, recent publications. Um, As
I said, like, um, It's called the PC work.
Essentially, as a, yeah. It's currently taking my um.
Most of my time to, to finalize this. Um,
BUT CSPress.com will basically be the place where I
would update uh in the future.
Great. So, Casper, thank you so much again for
taking the time to come on the show. It's
been a real pleasure to talk to you. Thank
you. Hi guys, thank you for watching this interview
until the end. If you liked it, please share
it, leave a like and hit the subscription button.
The show is brought to you by Enlights Learning
and Development done differently. Check their website at enlights.com
and also please consider supporting the show on Patreon
or PayPal. I would also like to give a
huge thank you to my main patrons and PayPal
supporters, Perergo Larsson, Jerry Mulleran, Frederick Sundo, Bernard Seyaz
Olaf, Alex, Adam Cassel, Matthew Whittingberrd, Arnaud Wolff, Tim
Hollis, Eric Elena, John Connors, Philip Forst Connolly. Then
Dmitri Robert Windegerru Inai Zu Mark Nevs, Colin Holbrookfield,
Governor, Michel Stormir, Samuel Andrea, Francis Forti Agnun, Svergoo,
and Hal Herzognun, Machel Jonathan Labran, John Yardston, and
Samuel Curric Hines, Mark Smith, John Ware, Tom Hammel,
Sardusran, David Sloan Wilson, Yasilla Dezaraujo Romain Roach, Diego
Londono Correa. Yannik Punter DaRosmani, Charlotte Blis Nicole Barbaro,
Adam Hunt, Pavlostazevski, Alekbaka Madison, Gary G. Alman, Semov,
Zal Adrian Yei Poltontin, John Barboza, Julian Price, Edward
Hall, Edin Bronner, Douglas Fry, Franco Bartolati, Gabriel Pancortezus
Suliliski, Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sony Smith, and
Wisman. Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Georg Jarno, Luke
Lovai, Georgios Theophanous, Chris Williamson, Peter Wolozin, David Williams,
Dio Costa, Anton Ericsson, Charles Murray, Alex Shaw, Marie
Martinez, Coralli Chevalier, Bangalore atheists, Larry D. Lee Jr.
Old Eringbon. Esterri, Michael Bailey, then Spurber, Robert Grassy,
Zigoren, Jeff McMahon, Jake Zul, Barnabas Raddix, Mark Kempel,
Thomas Dovner, Luke Neeson, Chris Story, Kimberly Johnson, Benjamin
Galbert, Jessica Nowicki, Linda Brendan, Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensleyman.
George Ekoriati, Valentine Steinmann, Per Crawley, Kate Van Goler,
Alexander Obert, Liam Dunaway, BR, Massoud Ali Mohammadi, Perpendicular,
Jannes Hetner, Ursula Guinov, Gregory Hastings, David Pinsov, Sean
Nelson, Mike Levin, and Jos Necht. A special thanks
to my producers Iar Webb, Jim Frank Lucas Stink,
Tom Vanneden, Bernardine Curtis Dixon, Benedict Mueller, Thomas Trumbull,
Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlomon Negro, Al Nick
Cortiz, and Nick Golden, and to my executive producers,
Matthew Lavender, Sergio Quadrian, Bogdan Kanis, and Rosie. Thank
you for all.